A 15-YEAR-OLD
BESPECTACLED TEENAGER.
UH-OH, LET ME SAY IT.
IT'S A HARD WORD,
"BESPECTACLED."
SHE TAKES THE BUS HOME
FROM SCHOOL,
SO HER FRIENDS ARE LIKE,
ALL RIGHT,
WE'RE HAVING A FUN TRIP
TO HOME.
UH-OH, A WHITE LADY.
A WHITE LADY
GETS ON THE BUS.
THE WHITE LADY'S LIKE,
HEY, YOU GUYS HAVE TO MOVE,
BECAUSE I'M WHITE.
CLAUDETTE'S FRIENDS LEAVE,
BUT CLAUDETTE STAYS,
AND IS LIKE, YOU KNOW WHAT,
I PAID MY FARE,
THE SAME AS THIS WHITE LADY
PAID HER FARE.
SO CLAUDETTE'S LIKE,
[bleep] YOU.
I'M [bleep] SITTING.
HAVE A SEAT.
WHITE LADY'S LIKE,
I WILL NOT HAVE A SEAT.
THE BUS DRIVER'S LIKE,
I'M GONNA GET THE COPS.
SO THE COPS ARE LIKE, MOVE.
CLAUDETTE'S LIKE,
I SHALL NOT BE MOVED,
AND THEY DRAG HER
OFF THE BUS.
THE ONLY THING SHE KNOWS
TO DO IS TO GO,
IT'S MY CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
AND THEY'RE LIKE, IT'S 1955,
AND WE DON'T HAVE TO DO [bleep],
SO [bleep] YOU.
CLAUDETTE'S LIKE,
[bleep] [bleep] 1955.
[burps]
I'M SORRY I BURPED,
BUT I'M NOT SORRY!
SO WAIT, WHAT?
SO THE N.A.A.C.P.
IS FLOODED WITH LETTERS SAYING,
CLAUDETTE COLVIN IS SO BRAVE,
SHE'S WONDERFUL.
AND THE PERSON
WHO READS THESE LETTERS,
THE SECRETARY OF THE N.A.A.C.P.,
ROSA PARKS.
ROSA PARKS GOES
TO CLAUDETTE COLVIN'S HOUSE
AND IS LIKE, CLAUDETTE,
YOU'RE THE [bleep].
CLAUDETTE'S LIKE,
I [bleep] KNOW.
I'M THE ONE WHO GOT MY ASS
DRAGGED TO JAIL.
AND THAT'S HOW THEY REALLY
CONNECT AND BECOME FRIENDS.
SO, WHENEVER SHE'S
AT AN N.A.A.C.P. MEETING,
SHE SPENDS THE NIGHT
AT ROSA PARKS' HOUSE.
AND ROSA PARKS IS LIKE,
YOU KNOW WHAT, YOU'RE GREAT.
CLAUDETTE COLVIN IS LIKE,
YOU'RE GREAT.
THEY REALLY CONNECT.
TIME PASSES, AND E.D. NIXON,
THE PRESIDENT OF THEIR LOCAL
CHAPTER OF THE N.A.A.C.P.,
IS LIKE, WE NEED
TO START A BUS BOYCOTT,
AND THIS BUS BOYCOTT
WILL START A REVOLUTION.
WE SHOULD USE
CLAUDETTE COLVIN'S ARREST
AS A REASON TO BOYCOTT
THE BUSES.
PEOPLE WILL GET BEHIND HER.
BUT THEN THEY WERE LIKE,
OH, BUT NOT WHITE PEOPLE,
BECAUSE SHE HAS DARKER SKIN,
AND WE CAN'T HAVE A 15-YEAR-OLD
AS THE FACE
OF THE ANTISEGREGATION MOVEMENT,
BUT WE CAN HAVE ROSA PARKS
AS THE FACE OF THIS MOVEMENT.
SO IT'S AT THAT TIME
THAT ROSA PARKS SITS DOWN
IN THE WHITE SECTION OF THE BUS
AND GETS TAKEN OFF TO JAIL,
BUT SHE HAD TO ACT LIKE,
OH, I WAS JUST TIRED.
AREN'T I NOT THREATENING,
WHITE PEOPLE?
AND THEN WHITE PEOPLE WERE LIKE,
OH, SHE'S JUST TIRED.
WE'RE EATING THIS UP.
OKAY.
[laughs]
I'M JUST, LIKE,
HYPERAWARE THAT, LIKE,
THIS VERY MOMENT
COULD BE ON NATIONAL TV.